Earthquakes.
Earthquakes are one of the natural phenomena
that have impacted the history of mankind
the most.
They have destroyed entire cities and taken
the lives of millions and millions of people.
That’s nothing new.
What is new, is knowing how to resist them,
how to survive and how to make safer buildings
and infrastructure.
That, folks, is a very new phenomenon.
And when it comes to earthquake proofing,
there are two countries that have had to learn
a lot.
Folks, Chile and Japan are the two most seismically
active countries on the planet.
Together they account for around 40% of all
seismic activity that happens in the world.
In fact, Chile has suffered the most powerful
earthquake ever recorded: the Valdivia earthquake
in 1960.
It recorded a magnitude of 9.5 on the Richter
scale.
A true cataclysm.
But this is not so unusual when you consider
that both Japan and Chile lie directly above
the Ring of Fire, a stretch of 40,000 kilometers
that accounts for the most seismic and volcanic
activity on earth.
In this zone, tectonic plates subduct, that
is, one slides under the other, generating
subduction zones.
The movement of the plates is not constant
or regular, it happens with sudden pulls,
and when both plates are very stressed and
have a lot of accumulated energy, they yield,
let go and move suddenly, generating strong
earthquakes.
That’s why 90% of all earthquakes in the
world and 80% of the most powerful ones, the
megathrust, happen in the Ring of Fire.
In fact, Japan and Chile’s earthquakes are
very similar in magnitude and duration.
As you can imagine, this challenge comes with
one choice: Adapt or die.
Today, on VisualPolitik, we’ll tell you
how these two countries managed to adapt,
what the main differences between them are
and the great common challenge that Japan
and Chile face.
Listen up.
(CHILE AND JAPAN, LEARNING FROM MISTAKES)
Folks, the most destructive earthquakes have
terrible consequences.
We’re talking about phenomena that can end
the lives of tens of thousands of people in
just a few minutes.
Chile and Japan are the most advanced countries
in seismic disaster prevention for one simple
reason, throughout their history they’ve
undergone terrible tragedies that have taught
them a very valuable lesson:
It’s worth spending more at the outset to
save on human and reconstruction costs.
But….
To better illustrate the magnitude of what
we’re talking about, let’s focus on just
one example.
March 11th, 2011 is one of those dates we’ll
all surely remember.
That day a huge 9.1 magnitude earthquake was
centred in Miyagi Prefecture in Japan, but
it shook a large part of the country, including
the capital, Tokyo.
The Great Eastern Earthquake and the subsequent
tsunami left almost 16,000 dead and more than
6,000 injured.
And yes, we’re talking about the same earthquake
that caused the Fukushima disaster.
This was Japan’s latest mega earthquake,
but, folks, the Japanese know that there’s
a 70% chance of another mega earthquake happening
in Tokyo in the next 30 years.
And yes, okay, the vast majority, more than
85% of Tokyo buildings are considered resistant,
but the fact that 16,000 hectares of the Japanese
capital is covered in wooden buildings doesn’t
help.
According to some simulations, the gas leaks
that are commonly produced by a large earthquake
could cause fires throughout the city and
could destroy more than 600 thousand buildings.
So the consequences go far beyond tremors
and possible landslides.
And of course, all this generates awareness;
both social and political.
Meanwhile in Chile, they are somewhat behind,
but the social shock of 2010 made them take
risk prevention even more seriously.
( An 8.8 magnitude earthquake shakes Chile.
The earthquake, lasting one minute, was felt
in the capital, where the electrical service
was interrupted.
The tsunami that the earthquake caused reached
Hawaii.
La Vanguardia 02/27/2019)
(Chile's earthquake was horrible - but it
could have been so much worse
Chile is one of South America's richest, best-organised
countries and many of its homes and offices
were built to be earthquake resistant.
The Guardian)
Folks, Chile’s earthquake affected 70% of
the country's population, but... thanks to
their anti-seismic regulations, for example,
only two of the capital’s high-rise buildings
collapsed.
And that, in the face of such a strong earthquake,
is quite a success, especially considering
the precedents of the Latin American region.
( “Chile's investments in resilient infrastructure,
early warning systems and urban planning have
managed to ensure that this time the number
of victims is low, despite the earthquake’s
intensity.”
Margareta Wahlström, former Office Special
Representative of the United Nations for Disaster
Risk Reduction.)
And this is what we need to repeat.
As the saying goes: better safe than sorry.
But, how have Japan and Chile achieved these
levels of risk prevention?
How do their models differ?
What are the weaknesses and keys to saving
lives?
(IF THERE’S A RISK, GET AHEAD OF IT)
When we talk about earthquakes, we must keep
two things in mind: they’re unpredictable
and inevitable.
However, what can be predicted and avoided
are the risks that arise when an earthquake
occurs.
You see, earthquake damage prevention can
be done in two ways: active or passive.
For example, After the Valdivia earthquake
of 1960, the strongest ever recorded, which
caused a huge tsunami, the Pacific Tsunami
Warning and Mitigation System was created
by the UNESCO Intergovernmental Oceanographic
Commission in 1965, intending to disseminate
early tsunami alerts.
Don't worry, the age of the system shouldn’t
scare you…
It’s been updated over time.
The fact is that this is one of the best examples
of active prevention.
A tsunami in the Pacific has a huge propagation
capacity, and can be very destructive.
Usually, there is about a 20 to 30-minute
window between an earthquake happening under
or near the sea and a tsunami hitting the
nearest coast.
But in the case of the 2011 earthquake in
Japan, in some areas, only two minutes passed
between the alert and the tsunami making landfall.
And of course, in the case of phenomena that
require massive evacuations and which affect
huge regions, early warnings are extremely
important, massively important.
The more time people have, the better.
Every second counts.
In fact, a strong earthquake originating in
Chile can cause such a large tsunami that
it can affect very distant coasts throughout
the Pacific, such as Japan, New Zealand, America
and even the Philippines.
And that is precisely why Japan also implemented
its own early warning system, which has been
greatly improved, since the 2011 catastrophe.
Since that year, more than 25 billion dollars
have been invested in earthquake sensors to
reach 280 points.
It’s the densest and most reliable network
in the world.
However, the biggest challenge, by far, is
passive prevention, that is, all those measures
and standards that aim to minimize damage
to buildings, and therefore, victims.
And in this, Japan is the undisputed leader.
(Japan’s Strict Building Codes Saved Lives.
The New York Times)
But, how exactly does it work?
Well...
Check it out.
Although the first Japanese anti-seismic construction
regulations date back to 1924, today most
of the buildings are built under two very
different regulations.
The oldest one, called kyu-taishin, dates
back to 1950, and focused on preventing the
buildings’ collapse.
The new code or shin-taishin, from 1981, requires
buildings to remain structurally sound and
show, at most,only cracks after medium-to-strong
earthquakes.
These rules have, evidently, been partially
reinforced over the years.
It’s precisely due to this that the structures
of the buildings in Japan are mostly made
out of steel, which is much more flexible
and resistant to movement than rigid concrete.
Furthermore, in some cases, cross beams that
absorb energy from the earthquake are also
installed.
And of course, they also have seismic dampers
at the base of the tallest buildings.
Chile, on the other hand, doesn’t require
buildings to withstand damage; regulations
are more oriented towards preventing their
collapse.
Its current regulation is a bit more similar
to the Japanese one of 1950.
In this aspect you can see the huge difference
in vision that Chile has, where the regulation
is much less strict.
That is to say, in Chile, they seek to save
lives, but without requiring buildings to
remain unscathed.
And there’s a fundamental reason for this:
the cost.
Building a building as resilient as those
in Japan can cost around 10 to 15% more than
a regular one.
And of course, this makes housing prices in
newer and more resistant buildings more expensive.
The philosophy is: “If you live here, you’ll
be safe.”
But, just a second.
We’re assuming that rules are always met
and codes are always followed, that everyone
is working for the common good, when the truth
may be quite different.
In fact, do you know what the number one problem
is that affects security and can cost many
lives?
Think about it for a second...
Precisely, you got it.
(ATTENTION, CORRUPTION KILLS)
Yes, you heard correctly.
It may surprise you, but corruption is, without
a doubt, the greatest threat to security in
terms of earthquakes.
And no, neither Japan nor Chile are free of
this scourge because, even though Japan has
the image of an ideal country and Chile ranks
a respectable number 27, in the corruption
perception index, from time to time, scandals
like this one crop up.
The KYB Corporation, a Japanese company dedicated
to the development and manufacture of seismic
dampers, admitted at the end of 2018, that
they had falsified the quality and performance
data of their products for more than a decade.
To this date, they haven’t yet been able
to quantify the real scope of the risk that
this entails, but it’s estimated that the
effectiveness of the falsified products could
be at around 86% of the minimum requirements
required by Law.
Buildings as important as Tokyo City Hall,
the Olympic Aquatics Center and the Ariake
Arena, home of the 2020 Olympic Games, used
seismic dampers from this company.
And as if that weren’t enough, the tallest
tower in the world does too.
Tokyo Skytree among buildings linked to data
scandal at earthquake shock absorber-maker
KYB Corp..
The Japan Times)
Although this case is quite serious, the truth
is that Japan doesn’t have much corruption,
and that means that seismic regulations are
followed most of the time.
Chile, on the other hand, has the lowest corruption
level in all of Latin America, which has contributed
to the fact that anti-seismic regulations
in construction are complied with in the vast
majority of cases.
Although, as we’ve seen, they are far less
stringent than Japan’s.
“We have a law that states that designs
of a certain height have to be reviewed by
an independent team that verifies that the
standards are being met.
No one builds without this backing.”
Sergio Sepúlveda, geology scholar from the
University of Chile, to El País.)
But you know what?
It’s precisely this broad compliance with
regulations that makes Chile a much safer
country to live in than, for example, Mexico,
during an earthquake.
Corruption and negligence caused landslides
during the Mexico City earthquake.
EFE)
Mexico, one of the countries with the highest
corruption rates in the region, is also a
highly seismic country.
The difference with Chile is that in Mexico’s
cities, every time there’s a strong earthquake
several buildings collapse, leaving numerous
victims.
And although not all earthquakes have the
same characteristics, for reasons such as
the type of soil and depth, Mexico City lost
228 people in the city alone, and 369 across
the entire country in the earthquake on September
19 2017.
On the other hand, the 2015 earthquake in
Coquimbo, Chile, which was felt with an intensity
of 7 in Santiago, only caused 15 fatalities
throughout the country.
A great example of earthquake preparation.
Therefore, folks, Mexico and other highly
seismic countries need to catch up and work
hard and honestly for the safety of their
citizens.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.
And as always, thanks for watching!